[Applause]
my
you were all talk when you left here but
you've nothing to show for it dee oh
we should have sell it forth in the
first place
surely the turn is mine
i believe it's my turn next honestly you
make more noise than the rabble at a
feast
even if you did stop its raging flow
it will soon burst through
well then
let us see how far the flow brings them
this time
[Music]
we each have a lifespan of 10 years
we call them terms
life begins with our first term and ends
at the close of our tenth
victory
and over the course of those 10 years
we fight continually
what kind of pep talk is
that of course we're gonna survive
i've thought about this a lot
about what i can achieve
i thought i'd be well i'll leave behind
forever by herself then i think of
tomorrow and the tremors are back
will i see the same faces when i wait
will i even be around
[Music]
get ready now
the enemy is before you
chase them to the ends of the world
unchecked uroboros will lead this world
to ruin you must be erased
these soldiers
[Music]
you gave us a choice
the choice not to fight
and you made it true
that marked there
late 10th term huh three months left
that about right
three more months
and then i'll be gone from this world
how many of you are getting made an
example
this time
the lost numbers
we have
good reason to meet with them
to bring peace
and to set the world to rights but take
a look around
think about how many lives it's called
annihilated
this is bad noah now i
want to live
to live
and
so don't give up yet this will buy you
some extra time use it stop this
i don't want any of your time if the
world holds our lives back i will end it
these are our lives here
it is fate
many have
tried but none have ever managed to
escape its flow
[Applause]
what is it they need to stay alive
water
food
certainly
but what we need most
is life itself
taking each other's lives
with the taken flames becoming your own
in turn
this is the world of ionios
the nations of kevis and agnes and their
grisly conflict stand in contrast to its
natural splendor
all this killing for the sake of filling
one's own flame clock
[Music]
from the moment of birth
fighting is all the people of ionios
learn
their fate leads to everyone's
destruction
their lifespans are a mere 10 years
surviving on the battlefield fulfilling
that 10-year lifespan of service and
receiving a homecoming ceremony in front
of their queen is the highest honor
[Music]
however
many never receive this honor
as they fall in
battle their souls evaporating into the
beyond
as the melody of the offsears plays
[Music]
in today's presentation we'll introduce
the world of the xenoblade chronicles 3
game
and follow the main character's
adventures
countless comrades have lost their lives
thanks to this
what you think it's like for us
losing friend after friend
you steal everything from us
six soldiers three from kevis and three
from agnes were commissioned to take
part in a special mission
both parties filled with mutual hatred
draw their weapons at first but when
they encounter a mysterious figure they
shelve their distrust and resolve to
work together because now kids
you share a common destiny they'll hunt
you constantly
relentlessly without rest
there's one place that might give you a
chance
[Music]
march the land pierced by a great sword
our city
defeat the real enemy
and restore the world to order
[Music]
this story focuses on these six
characters
this is what we're meant to do
to send on the voices of the departed
is an offseason's purpose
ready he says
from the moment i chose this muddy path
i've been more than ready
[Music]
sparky what about
i'm not gonna let you take the fall
alone
i thought about this a lot
about what i can achieve
what i'll leave behind
[Music]
if anything we should be questioning all
that we've thought to be true
differences are all a matter of
perspective
the truth is
she's terrified she needs someone to
tell her
that everything will be all right
now fugitives of both kevis and agnes
these fate-defying hopefuls journey to
learn the truths of their world
[Music]
their role is to convey the queen's
directive to the colonies along with
handling admin and decision making
our colonies regard each other as
enemies
but if the consoles given the orders are
the same it means that these guys are
mega suspicious
i suspect they may be more deeply
involved than we thought
with the reason why we fight with
deciding our fate
our fate
[Music]
keep it together now mimi
hey look there
maybe look it's water there's an oasis
water
water
let's just hope it's not a mirage
[Music]
ionios is host to various landscapes
all filled with surreal geography to
explore and diverse wildlife to
encounter
like the lands they inhabit
the wild creatures here range from
docile
to dangerous
[Music]
some creatures make no secret of their
ferocious tendencies
so keep caution in mind
you'll also encounter the soldiers of
kevis and agnes who continue to fight
throughout the land
[Music]
colonies serve as the base camp for both
nations
at the heart of each colony is a furanus
these are mobile bases and devastating
weapons of war
seek out these colonies to shock
[Applause]
dine
[Music]
get to know residents and more
[Music]
get a glimpse of the lives of noah and
his friends at these rest spots found in
colonies and throughout the world
use collected materials to cook
[Music]
craft gems to strengthen your abilities
looks good to me i think we'll find this
useful
and discuss information you hear about
from residents to take on new quests
[Music]
explore every corner of these fields as
you seek out new encounters
breathtaking scenery
valuable items
[Music]
and ferocious monsters
enjoy the world and fulfill your
wanderlust at your own pace
[Music]
the locations you visit are saved as
landmarks that you can quickly select
and travel to
which makes traversing this giant world
more manageable
[Music]
by enabling a navigation feature you can
set a course for your next destination
without fear of losing your way
there are plenty of other features that
will help you on your adventure such as
the ability to change the time of day to
encounter monsters that only appear at
specific times
[Music]
lance
draw his attention for me unique cover
fire leave it to me tile set up we need
you to
understood just say when guys thanks
everyone
i'll count down from three
three
two
one
let's go
[Music]
draw your weapon when encountering an
enemy to seamlessly enter battle
make your approach to attack
automatically then harness powerful
abilities called arts to strive for
victory
arts have a variety of effects
some can throw opponents off balance
inflict more damage based on where you
attack from
or heal allies to name a few
each art is assigned to a button making
them simple and easy to execute
each character takes on a specific role
during battle
attackers excel at damaging enemies
defenders block enemy attacks and draw
their aggro
and healers can restore hp to keep you
in fighting shape
each character playing their role
effectively is a key point to battling
you can freely swap the character you
control at any time
string together arts to activate a combo
and gain an advantage
get the enemy off balance
knock them to the ground
launch them into the air then smash them
down
stringing together successful combos is
quite satisfying
you can link multiple arts with stunning
chain attacks to devastate enemies
[Music]
deal heaps of damage at once and let
nothing stand in your way
[Music]
what is it
an icon just popped up
over your head
[Music]
who seems to be the only one not locked
huh
he's lit up like a sparkling light bulb
i've never used this kind of blade
before
but all the techniques i can use with it
are flashing before my eyes
each character in your party has a class
that influences how they battle
then how this is even working but cool
each class has its own attributes
sword fighter
lead the fight with this well-balanced
attacker class
zephyr
evade attacks and unleash powerful
counters
restore allies hp and strengthen their
abilities from a position of safety
tactician
disrupt enemies and support allies using
paper talismans called mondo
heavy guard
[Music]
wield massive weapons to defend allies
and draw enemy aggro
ogre
[Music]
crush enemy defenses with massive power
your class can also be changed to match
that of your allies spend time learning
multiple classes for a well-rounded team
experience earned on the battlefield
increases your class rank and lets you
learn master arts a set of beneficial
arts that can be added to a different
class
with master arts even your defender can
take a moment to heal their allies
the more arts and combat strategies you
wield the easier it'll be to blaze
through battles
[Music]
also by combining compatible arts you
can unleash fusion art attacks that
combine the effects of two arts into one
die spectacularly
that's how i want the battlefield of my
life to be
just that as a mechanic you can't start
getting moody just because something's
broken
now we see real number one potential
that's right maybe it's impossible for
one
but not for two
i just wish it wasn't such a weakling
i can't run away from my responsibility
[Music]
doing the same as everyone around you
it's always the same outcome
following the playbook to the letter is
hardly a strategy
whoever goes up against me
are getting crushed
brave residents of ionios called
can land their arms and aptitude to your
team as a seventh party member
[Music]
only one hero at a time can assist on
the battlefield but you can swap them
out as you see fit
heroes also bring their own classes to
your team
guardian commander
turn the tables with boosted abilities
when things look dire
in cursor
unleash more critical hits for higher
attack power
war medic
heal party members and bolster them with
various
[Music]
buffs these are only a handful of
classes that heroes bring
your party members can take on any of
the hero classes as they become your
allies
recruit more heroes for a growing
combination of classes and arts in your
party
choose to don a class's look or keep
your current outfit
find your fashion and fight for the
future
[Music]
[Music]
something else
you've got a real death wish
get out the way you're just slowing me
down the nerve on this guy
one day
good start
it's not over yet
[Music]
i felt her thoughts
or maybe her memories
there were so many
and then they were a part of me
[Music]
by joining together in battle through
interlinking two characters in your
party can fuse into a fiercely powerful
form known as an oroboros
here are the character pairs that can
interlink
transform into this fierce infusion by
interlinking during combat
clear out the battlefield by using
mighty oroboros arts before time is up
and the interlude deactivates
[Music]
[Music]
those guys are so
selfish
selfish how
you know what i mean
every time we interlink they're the ones
taking the lead
so you'd prefer to take the raids
i just want to do
more like pull my weight
you know
lamp come with me
i'm all set
despite being a single body the
auroboris is controlled by only one of
the two characters
swap between them to modify the form and
arts of the aura bores to fit your
approach
earn points in battle to make the
already powerful oroboros even stronger
do you want to add to the playbook
[Music]
aura can also take part in chain attacks
with the rest of the party
[Music]
we were sworn enemies once
and yet
we all share the will to live in the now
until now i was afraid to take that
first step
but now
i can do it
not like
we can afford to go just yet
[Music]
so now i ain't afraid
yeah i'll keep going
while my flame still flickers a bit
around
but i'm gonna change
both me and this world
we'll build it for ourselves a world
with the freedom to choose
[Music]
[Music]
broaden the world of xenoblade
chronicles 3 with a paid expansion pass
you can get the additional content shown
here
xenoblade chronicles 3 is compatible
with amiibo figures tap any amiibo to
acquire helpful in-game items for your
adventure
tap the shulk amiibo to change a
character sword to appear as the monado
when using noah's sword fighter class
xenoblade chronicles 3
launches july 29th
thank you for watching
and enjoy your adventures in the world
of ionios